Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz is almost
certainly running for president
excitingly precisely zero percent of
Americans who actually consider
themselves fiscally conservative and
socially liberal we will examine that
empty slogan as well as Howard Schultz's
empty campaign then comrade Bernie
dances shirtless with the Soviets oh my
eyes oh my eyes a Catholic Cardinal
won't excommunicate New York Governor
and equal mo for killing babies and some
good news on the culture I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
there's a story I'm gonna try to get to
later on today about how your iPhone is
spying on you're not just spying on you
it actually you can spy on other people
using your iPhone you can force them to
answer a call even if they don't know
that they've answered it you can hear
what they're saying
all of this we'll get to that in a bit
all of this should remind you that you
should protect what you're doing on the
Internet
with all the recent news about online
security breaches it is hard not to
worry about where my data goes making an
online purchase or simply accessing your
email could put your private information
at risk not look if you're watching this
show you probably do some pretty weird
stuff on the Internet
make sure that you can protect your data
you're being tracked by social media
sites marketing companies and removal
and internet provider take back your
security using Express VPN expressvpn
has easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly
in the background of my computer phone
and tablet turning it on takes only one
that click expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address protecting yourself
with expressvpn how much would you pay
for that you pay all the money in the
world but it only costs less than seven
bucks a month protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months free at expressvpn comm
slash michael mi CH AE e l exp ress VPN
comm slash michael mi CH AE l for three
months free with a one-year package what
does that address I'll tell you again
expressvpn dot-com slash Michael to
learn more all right before we get to
all of the weird stuff that you're doing
on the Internet today and how people can
spy on you using your iPhone and all
these other nefarious security breaches
let's talk about the greatest story of
the 2020 election I'm not talking about
the Kamala Harris I'm not talking about
Bernie Sanders I'm not talking about
debate oo Roark I'm not talking about
any of those people I'm talking about
the Howard Schultz independent Democrat
bid for the presidency Howard Schultz is
the CEO of Starbucks we talked about him
a little bit yesterday he's very
left-wing he's a lifelong Democrat
it seems that
he is going to run I am seriously
considering running for president as a
centrist independent and I wanted to
clarify the word independent which I
view merely as a designation on the
ballot not going great it's up there
Howard Schultz is saying I'm really
seriously thinking about running and I'm
a Democrat but I'm not gonna run in the
Democrat primary why because he couldn't
possibly win the Democrat primary so I'm
thinking about running on a third party
as an independent and then you just hear
this obvious Democrat voter in the
audience don't throw the election to
Trump you egotistical billionaire jerk
he says a different word in the greatest
surprise of all this Howard Schultz
possible candidacy the idea of running
as an independent Democrat the emotions
expressed by that left-wing protester in
the audience they have all conspired to
make the New York Times publish an
accurate op-ed today I know I don't
nobody saw this one coming the New York
Times published a spot-on absolutely
gets it right
op-ed by Michelle Goldberg it is called
Howard Schultz please don't run for
president in the reasoning why it's not
just because he's gonna throw the
election to trump although one hopes
that he would run and that he would
throw the election to trump but what it
really gets down to is this ridiculous
slogan and label that people use which
is well I'm a fiscal conservative but a
social liberal Michelle Goldberg writes
quote Schultz appears to share the
conviction endemic among American elites
that the country hungers for a candidate
who is socially liberal but fiscally
conservative after all if you're rich
you probably know a lot of people like
this I'm a social liberal fiscally
conservative centrist who would love to
vote for a rational Democrat and get
Trump out of the White House a chief
executive of a major bank who wanted to
remain anonymous recently told POLITICO
lamenting Michael Bloomberg's poor odds
in a Democratic primary but this
frustrated
decadence politics aren't widely shared
by people who haven't been to Davos in a
20-17 study the political scientist lead
ruttman plotted the 2016 electorate
along two axes one dealing with social
issues and identity the other economics
and trade only 3.8 percent of voters
fell into the socially liberal
economically conservative quadrant and
this is certainly true actually more
people identified as socially
conservative and fiscally liberal like
seven or eight times as many people
identified as socially conservative and
fiscally liberal then identified as
fiscally conservative and socially
liberal there is this is a joke among
the elites though virtually all elite
people I know you know the ones who grew
up in apartments on the Upper West Side
and they go to very fancy schools and
they know how to drink Cheveley they
fall into this category well I'm
fiscally conservative but I'm socially
liberal which means I don't believe in
anything but I do like money that's all
it means and some college conservative
types fall into this the reason I bring
it up the reason it strikes so close to
home is that I would have called myself
a fiscal conservative and social liberal
for a long time probably from the time I
was 16 until I don't know 21 22 23
something like something in there this
this is just the natural the natural
course for libertine people who are not
economically stupid because fiscal what
fiscal conservatism means is I've taken
an economics course at some point and I
think that we should efficiently
distribute goods throughout an economy
the you know the the elitism of this
there was an episode of 30 rock where
Liz Lemon this awful boyfriend Dennis
you know he just always says things that
are so awful and she said what are your
politics he says I would say I'm a
social conservative fiscal liberal and
this was a joke because for anybody who
wrote on 30 rock this was exactly the
opposite of what they thought
it's it's the cry of the elites on both
the left and the right GOP donors think
like this I've talked to a lot of big
GOP donors a lot of big party
muckety-mucks almost universally they
say oh gosh I wish we would give up on
all this abortion and gay marriage stuff
I come on let's just lower taxes maybe
we can reform entitlements and let
people do whatever they want in the
culture and this is a classic example of
trying to sever effect from cause you
know one of the hallmarks of the left I
always find as they want the appearance
of the thing but they don't want the
thing itself
they eat needless bacon they drink
decaffeinated coffee they they want all
of the niceties of civilization but they
don't want any of the discipline and the
virtue and the culture of civilization
so what when I was a fiscal conservative
social liberal in college as as many
people listening to this might be I one
time Ann Coulter came to college and so
I was talking to her and she said listen
kids I know that a lot of you are social
liberals but if if all you care about is
lowering taxes and you've got to
politicians in front of you one who is
pro-life and one who is pro-abortion
vote for the pro-life politician he will
lower your taxes more and this is a
really wise words because on the one
hand you think well what does one have
to do with the other what does the way
people think about babies or the way
people think about gay marriage or what
what does that have to do with lowering
taxes what it means is that fiscal
conservatism flows naturally from social
conservatism but social conservatism
does not flow naturally from fiscal
conservatism not necessarily I think of
this as a stage of conservative
development so I'm not too harsh on
college kids who would say I'm fiscally
conservative socially liberal but I am
harsh on CEOs of Starbucks because that
guy's just probably beyond hope at this
point I mean that he has reached the
stage of I'm a billionaire
I like to keep my money but I don't care
about anything other than myself
basically I think the reason this is
popular among a lot of people the
billionaire's and the college kids is a
it's the most material it's the most
tangible it's so easy to make the
argument I should keep my money
economy's where people have secured
property rights are really efficient
it's so easy to make that argument it's
much more difficult it's much more
uncomfortable especially in college
campuses today to explain why gay
marriage is not a legitimate category
because then people accuse you of you
don't like gay people or you hate gays
or you're sexually obsessed or whatever
of course there are the ones who are
sexually obsessed the left is the one
whose foisting sex on us but then you
have to explain to them the
complementarity of the sexes you have to
explain how men and women are actually
different you have to explain to them
that our views come from a realist
epistemology that we're describing
objective truth not merely subjective
experience you have to you go down this
whole rabbit island for a lot of people
they haven't thought through these ideas
it's easy to say I made this money I
want to keep this money you don't need
to think a lot to realize that but to
understand why objective reality exists
why men and women are different and
complementary why we shouldn't kill
babies in the womb even if we can't see
them it actually does require a ballast
of belief it requires some real depth of
thought that unfortunately the vast
majority of people in our culture today
don't have all the way from billionaire
CEOs all the way down to college kids
the really tangible issue with fiscal
conservative social liberal is it
doesn't work in reality what really
successful politicians in all of history
have been fiscal conservatives and
social liberals can unit one basically
you could name which is Bill Clinton and
even that isn't really true Bill Clinton
was a big government left winger until
he lost his midterm elections in 1994
and then he moderated because he doesn't
really believe anything and he just
wants to be popular but 94 to 2000 you
get the Bill Clinton fiscal conservative
social liberalism right he reformed
welfare he lowered taxes okay great
other than him and I don't know that
anybody wants to replicate Bill Clinton
I don't think when people are thinking
I want to go into public service I want
to be a world historical figure I want
to really mold the world for the good I
can't wait to be like Bill Clinton I
don't nobody says that but who else
falls into that category I can't think
of any I just think of the pipe dreams
of billionaires who are sitting drinking
their brandy in their studies on the
Upper East Side saying oh goodness if we
would just get rid of all this little
riffraff abortion business then we'd
finally win elections what are what are
we talking about Republicans do a great
job of winning elections when we appeal
to the culture explicitly when we appeal
to the culture culture is all that
matters
everything else is bean-counting you
raise tax rates a little you lower tax
rates a little okay it all comes from
the culture if you find yourself in the
position where you're a fiscal
conservative and a social liberal ask
yourself why are you a fiscal
conservative are you a fiscal
conservative because you like money we
all like money but and money is not the
root of all evil but the love of money
is the root of all evil I hope you're
not obsessed with money so we like money
okay is it because you think it's
efficient economics this is a better
argument you say look economies work
better Society works better when people
get to keep more of their money then
they can invest it in businesses those
businesses can invest in both capital
and labor they can hire people people
are working they're being productive
they've got incentives because people
are driven at least in part by
self-interest and you can align
incentives and everybody's happy okay
good that's pretty good but even that is
not sufficient that's a sort of
utilitarian
view of the world that we get from
Jeremy Bentham we have from John Stuart
Mill but it doesn't really encapsulate
the whole of the world I mean those two
guys Bentham and mill were so opposed to
the father of modern conservative
thought Edmund Burke so opposed to the
people that we draw our conservative
thought from who were in a real sense
romantic they they don't just like
efficient economics they don't like
little tabulations and say oh we can
increase GDP X percent if we just let
people keep this much more of their
money they like the diversity of the
world
they like the
riot II they they are drawn by
veneration they're drawn by aw by wonder
by tradition by prescription by the all
of these wonderful things that we have
that you can't put down on tablets the
the one of the great quotes from
reflections on the revolution in France
he says the age of chivalry is gone that
of Sophos ters economists and
calculators has succeeded and the glory
of Europe is extinguished forever and I
think those people who say I'm a fiscal
conservative social liberal because it's
really efficient in an economic sense
they are the age of Sophos ters
economists and calculators who cares had
the economy is going if you don't have
the glories of our society the glories
of civilization now one other reason
which is the correct reason to be a
fiscal conservative is because fiscal
conservatism comes naturally from your
thoughts on politics and the culture and
religion ultimately religion let's not
forget I know these days some Catholic
people like to talk about how great
socialism is the Catholic Church has
condemned socialism multiple times in
multiple papal encyclicals John Paul the
second did it in an encyclical called
chant as he was honest he said free
markets are are the most efficient way
to organize economies but he doesn't end
it at efficiency he he grounds that in a
moral sense this draws from pope leo
xiii who had encyclicals called rerum
Novarum and quad up astrology moon aries
i think it was called where he condemns
socialism he says socialism is totally
inhuman anti humans it's a it's opposed
to the natural order as opposed to what
God wants for us our ideas about free
markets about free economies which is
now where we have modern capitalism that
comes from the 16th century church that
comes from the school of Salamanca that
comes from the natural law or ideas of
natural rights we should have security
of our property that comes from the
natural law and the natural law comes
from considering the natural law giver
the the author of all of nature it is
perfectly natural to get that fish
conservatism out of what we would now
call social conservatism tradition or
sense of the culture or sense of
religion it makes a lot of sense but if
you try to flip it you don't make any
sense at all we've been talking a lot on
the show recently about how the Left
always inverts the culture they always
get things exactly backwards they think
that strength is weakness they think
that injustice is justice and they call
it social justice they get things
exactly backwards this is an example of
that and it's a product of a culture
that is dominated by the left it's uh it
would be such an instructive candidacy
if Howard Schultz would run it would be
so good it would first of all would fill
up my tumbler right up to the brim it
would probably throw Trump the election
so come on baby come on Howard do it do
it buddy but what it would do is also
expose the absurd lie to both the left
and the right of fiscal conservatism
social liberalism and it would cause us
to stop just arguing around the margins
arguing over oh this tax rate or this
tax rate it would actually get us to
talk about the culture which is what all
of our discussions really are it's it's
a frequently cited political truism
which has been variously attributed to a
lot of different authors that all
political battles are really theological
battles you're not just talking about
how trade policy can affect wines and
cheeses or this or that what you're
really talking about is what does it
mean to be a person what does it mean to
be a person living in society how should
we relate to one another and how do we
ground how we relate to one another well
it's how we relate to the divine it's
how we relate to our author it's how we
view ourselves those are the real
profound questions of politics and
Howard Schultz in a candidacy that is
already immolating it is already just
spontaneously combusting his leftist
protesters are calling him a jerk just
within 90 seconds of his quasi kickoff
it would be very instructive for the
country and it would be a lot of fun to
watch which is really really what I care
about in politics it's not a question of
fiscal conservatism and social
liberalism of
when it comes to our favorite socialist
Bernie Sanders he is a fiscal
totalitarian and a social totalitarian
so we knew that Bernie Sanders has an
affinity for dictators we know that he
has an affinity for communist slave
states he actually took his honeymoon in
the 80s in the Soviet Union but it
wasn't until today that this beautiful
little gem popped out Bernie Sanders
traveling to the Soviet Union in June of
1988 shirtless drinking singing this
land is your land a song by an American
communist named Woody Guthrie Bernie
take it away
[Applause]
for those of you who can't see there is
burning looking just like Bernie talking
to some Russian accent ammonia's got the
horn-rimmed glasses he's got his
crazy-looking hair completely shirtless
slumped over because he has bad posture
[Applause]
hi
[Applause]
Chinchin I guess I'll raise my glass of
leftist tears I would like this video to
put to rest forever the left ridiculous
hypocrisy on Trump colluding with Russia
the American Left has colluded with
Russia beginning in 1917 all the way up
to the present the American Left has
colluded and not just with the modern
Russians who are relatively sort of nice
guys compared to the old Russians who
were Soviet slave state dictator
totalitarian murderers thugs the worst
people on the face of the earth Bernie
Sanders chooses to have his honeymoon
there to sing to drink to be shirtless
for some reason don't know what they're
doing don't really want to know what
they're doing
how absurd to say they're now colluding
with the Russians Barack Obama just a
few years ago was sitting next to the
head of Russia met Medvedev the fake
head of Russia because Putin was really
the head of Russia and he said let what
let them know I'll have more flexibility
after my next election and then you hear
Medvedev leaned and he says duh if it
transmits this information to Vladimir
Jon's and I vowed to suck your blood
he he actually colluded on a hot mic
with the Russians Bernie Sanders here so
you say okay if colluding with the
Russians is so bad how come the left did
it for a hundred years
if colluding with the Russians is so bad
I come Bernie Sanders had his honeymoon
there of course it's crazy now the other
thing this tape reminds me of is that
Bernie Sanders is this lovable old coot
isn't he oh he's so lovable he's got
that crazy hair and that silly Queens
accent and he's got his glasses and all
he's so lovable and old and then you
think about this
and then you see that video you know an
Alexandria Casio Cortez another
socialist proud socialist oh she's young
and pretty and bubbly okay and that well
and then you think about this because
after all the funny bubbly crazy hair ah
ha ha Bernie what they are doing is
supporting wicked ideas and not just
wicked ideas but the embodiment of those
wicked
in wicked regimes here is Bernie Sanders
partying with Soviets in the 1980s
partying loves it can't get enough of it
one of the worst nations one of the
worst states ever to exist on the face
of the earth as a matter of this of the
scale of human misery Soviet the Soviet
Union under Stalin was worse than Nazi
Germany just as a matter of scale there
might be a difference in wickedness
which which gives Hitler the edge over
Stalin but really you're talking about
arsenic and cyanide this is a wicked
wicked slave regime and that's what they
support that's what they said with the
entire American left supported the
regime in Venezuela that turned it into
a an awful starving slave state where
people are eating rats in the streets
the American left Sean Penn sheared it
on the American left loved Hugo Chavez
socialist Venezuela and what it's led to
is unspeakable misery down there it's
it's very confusing it's really hard
because what we see on TV is cute old
Bernie Sanders cute little Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez oh it can't be that bad
you got to watch these videos I mean
this is where President Trump really has
a sense of politics and it's where the
culture is so much more important than
little accounting books for the fiscal
conservatives which is the culture
dominates what you see is what what
affects you when I see Bernie Sanders
crazy on a stage what what do I really
care when I see him cheering and dancing
half-naked for some reason along with
Soviets in the 80s that really puts it
into perspective and this is how
Hollywood always manipulates our
politics is on any issue they shun
whenever it's their issue it's the
sunniest rosiest most wonderful they can
make abortion look glamorous and they do
make abortion look glamorous but well
what about the Conservatives what about
did you see the movie vice vice which
just lied it patently live just one exam
in the movie vice about Dick Cheney they
have an entire scene where Dick Cheney
orders his chief of staff Scooter Libby
to leak the identity of Valerie Plame we
know that didn't happen we know that
didn't happen because of an
investigation which showed that the leak
came from the State Department not from
the office of the vice president doesn't
matter they lie they turned Cheney
starts soliloquizing like a
Shakespearean villain they they're just
these awful contorted terrible and
that's what you see and that's what you
think of I mean that's what you believe
also just a little side note where did
they get this video how did Hillary
Clinton not have this video of Bernie in
2016 maybe they thought it would have
helped Bernie among the Democrat
electorate but this video was leaked by
the head of the draft bado campaign
which almost certainly I've been around
a lot of draft candidate campaigns very
often they're being encouraged by the
candidates and so I'm sure bado is
basically working with these guys and so
the bado team dug up this video of
Bernie Sanders from the 80s where was
Hillary Clinton on this in 2016 I'm just
another example of a terribly run
presidential campaign and it's not just
Bernie by the way it's not just Bernie
into aoc Kamala Harris to is is
embracing socialism and this should send
up a warning sign for everybody because
Kamala Harris is the calculating
politician she is the there was a story
it came out yesterday a San Francisco
mayor said that he dated her and she
willingly dated this guy who was twenty
or thirty years older just to advance
her career she's the cold calculator
she's the Hillary four-point-oh I guess
she couldn't be Hillary to point now and
she is trending towards socialism this
is going to dominate the Democrat
primary we'll see what she has to say
then we'll get to whether or not we
should excommunicate the governor of New
York over abortion and then there
actually is some good news about the
culture but first if you were on Daily
wire calm thank you
you keep the lights on you keep COFA a
mic up if you are on facebook or youtube
go to daily wire it's ten bucks a month
100 hours for an annual membership you
get me you get the end replevin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you test
questions in the mail bag you test
questions backstage which we're doing
allowed now you get
see another Kingdom you get them out
well [ __ ] you get everything ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership none
of those things matter this is what
matters the left is tears tumblr it's
going to be a long 2020 campaign you're
gonna see a lot of videos of shirtless
bernie sanders your i don't know
specifically if you're gonna say that
you're gonna see a lot of similar videos
you're gonna see videos along that line
you are going to need your tumblr
otherwise you will drown go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
so from the fiscal socialist social
socialist wing of the Democrat Party
which is the whole Democrat Party
we now have Kamala Harris who's on CNN
she's speaking with Jake Tapper and she
gives her explanation of a problem the
Democrats have had to think about for a
while now the question was if you have a
government taking over most or all of
our health care system then how does the
patient get to keep his choices choice
of insurances choice of doctor and the
insurance companies get to maintain
their choice and their liberty and their
competition to keep Kosta how do you get
to keep choice in the system if the
government takes over health care Kamala
Harris has her new answer if you follow
up on that and correct me if I'm wrong
to reiterate you support the Medicare
for all bill I think initially
co-sponsored by Senator Bernie Sanders
you're also a co-sponsor I believe it
will totally eliminate private insurance
so for people out there who like their
insurance what they don't get to keep it
well the listen and the idea is that
everyone gets access to medical care and
you don't have to go through the process
of going through an insurance company
having them give you approval going
through the paperwork all of the delay
that may require who of us has not had
that situation where you got to wait for
approval and the doctor says well I
don't know if your insurance company is
gonna cover this let's eliminate all of
that let's move on let's eliminate all
that let's let's move on look let's
eliminate the greatest health care
regime in the history of the world that
basically single-handedly provides
health care innovation toward to the
entire world the place that everybody
goes when they want medical care
let's eliminate it you know like what
did that ever do for us other than be
the greatest achievement of healthcare
science ever other than that come on
move on this is the sign of the radical
and the sign of the reformer is there
they will bulldoze centuries of work on
a whim they don't care they have no
respect for anything they are utterly
filled with pride and so they say
whatever I don't yeah I don't
it's oh yeah I just don't love it so
just bulldoze it who cares well I don't
we'll probably be able to recreate the
culmination of centuries of science in
like a day right and add on to it
something that has never succeeded ever
which is government control of
healthcare yeah let's whatever no no
who cares it's only 1/6 of the economy
and the healthcare of 300 million
Americans whatever how ridiculous
how flippant what an unserious person to
say that sort of thing also it's a lie
everybody has access to medical care in
the United States she's she can't answer
it because you're right people won't get
to be able to choose their doctor they
won't be able to get to choose who
provides their health care so she has to
answer a different question she says
yeah okay well but everyone is gonna
have access to medical care everyone in
the United States has access to medical
care illegal aliens in the United States
can access medical care whenever they
want she is right that the system is
terrible she's right it is it's like
that Churchill quote about democracy
democracy is the worst form of
government except for all of the others
that have been tried the American
healthcare system is the worst form of
health care other than all the other
systems that have been tried that's true
it's so frustrating I go to the doctor
once every 50 years and I so I go get a
check-up or something and I'll get
random bills for this and it really
costs ten thousand dollars but you're
only paying three installments of $28
and somebody's paying this and your den
is all all of the costs are hidden from
both the providers and from the
customers so you're not really making
decisions based on any sort of market
incentives it's wide full of corruption
full of abuse full of inefficiency and
fat that's all true Kamala Harris's idea
is worse government health care is worse
it's true
our current system has a lot of
bureaucratic paperwork do we really
think that a government takeover of
health care is going to result in less
paperwork have you been to the DMV have
you been to Oh the Social Security
office oh you know that's sort of the
crown jewel of government paperwork as
when is the government ever reduced
paperwork you know at least when I get
some weird bill or something from my
insurance provider I can call up my
insurance
Vidor I can call up the medical office
that I go to now there are a lot of
little boutique medical offices now
there are certain things where you pay a
little bit of money and then you get to
this and that boo okay and you get to at
least tailor it more toward your tastes
well still we have a very robust social
safety net that takes care of everybody
we have a very generous Medicaid system
to take care of the poor we have a very
generous Medicare system to take care of
the elderly we have emergency rooms for
people who aren't even u.s. citizens we
just give them medical care we have a
basically wonderful health care system
with a lot of inefficiencies that you
can that you could fix or make a little
bit better gradually mind you not all at
once not ripping it to the ground like
this lunatic reformer Kamala Harris but
gradually instituting reforms that would
make costs clearer that would free up
some of these markets that would allow
for a little bit more competition
certain places it would lift some
regulations that would include tort
reform so that you don't have crazy
malpractice laws where doctors are
afraid to do anything ordering a zillion
tests you there are a lot of reforms
that you could make gradually to make
the system even better than it is or you
could take the Kamala Harris Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez Democrat Medicare for all
approach which is to bulldoze the
greatest health care system ever on
which the entire world relies and then
just cross your fingers and hope that a
system that has consistently failed will
work here just cuz those are your
options those are your two options we'll
see which one they do there's an
important observation here I guess it
plays on the radical reform ideas of
Kamala Harris it was first made by
George canning the observation is that
all simple forms of government are bad
that's it in our society which is
increasingly egalitarian increasingly
democratic increasingly simple
increasingly leveling all we want is
just simple simple simple it's just this
is health care a right or a privilege
we're just gonna fill out one form we're
just gonna do one thing what one size
fits all for everybody all 50 states
it's all simple it's all so that that's
always bad that's what the
French Revolution was was really simple
really really simple wasn't it oh we're
all gonna just have quadrants of a
country and no no neighborhoods no
states no natural boundaries no ties of
kinship or family no private
relationships between insurance
contractors and medical doctors no
personal relationships between you and
your doctor nope no more of that guys
it's just gonna be simple and it always
fails it's alway it always leads to
misery because life isn't simple they
say well it's gonna be really clear all
shallows are clear shallow systems are
clear they're clearly wrong they're
clearly bad they're clearly ineffective
all shallows are clear
don't nobody benefits because life is
not simple life is not clear life is
complex it is rich it is diverse it is
beautiful it is terrible it is awesome
it is awful it is all of these things
our relationships to one another I have
a relationship do I have a relationship
to the federal government and that's it
and is it like during the Obama 2012
campaign the life of Julia were attract
this American woman Julia from cradle to
grave and the only meaningful
relationship that she had in that entire
process was with the federal government
is that what life is no that's a horror
that's a nightmare of what life is what
what are the relationships that we have
a relationship to my producers I have a
relationship to my left is tears tumblr
it's kind of a romantic relationship
frankly and it gets a little
inappropriate sometimes but it's
complicated and I think the tumblr would
say the same thing I just love it so
much I have a relationship to my
employers I have a relationship to my
friends I have a relationship to my wife
my family my extended family my mayor my
congressman my senator I've give final a
my federal government I have a
relationship to my church I have a
relation I have all of these
relationships
that's what's rich that's not simple
that's very complicated I can't write it
out in a little pamphlet I can't make it
some doctrinaire ideology can't put it
into a manifesto but that's life and
when you can put something into a little
ideology a little manifesto
a little Kamala Harris quote
medicare-for-all or can people choose
now they can't choose anything simple
that that's how you know that something
has gone horribly wrong
so for 2020 what this means this
Democrats are going all in on socialism
this is why Schulz can't run in the
Democrat primary even though he is a
Democrat he's a lifelong Democrat he
just would never get elected he is not a
socialist he thinks that medic he
actually came out and said it
that Kamala Harris's medicare-for-all
idea is unamerican and it is it's on
American and anti American but Kamala
Harris is the future of the Democrat
Party maybe she's not she might get
wiped out in the primaries but her ideas
or her approach is she's a weathervane
she's a calculating politician when she
sees that things are moving in the
Bernie direction they're not moving in
the Bill Clinton direction she's gonna
go that way and you're gonna see that
everybody is gonna follow her it's it's
a total extremism and you see the
extremism not just on the fiscal front
nor on things that emanated from that
I'm not just on health care you see it
on social issues as well you see it on
life you see it in New York we talked
about that crazy abortion law in New
York Andrew Cuomo the governor there
signed this law a week or two ago which
now makes it legal to kill an unborn
baby up to one minute before it's born
if the baby is due to be born at 12:03
at 12:02 you can go in and rip that baby
apart that's perfectly legal now in New
York actually it goes even further that
law reforms the Penal Code so it now in
the old days in New York if a if a
murderer goes up and kills a pregnant
woman a woman who's more than 24 weeks
pregnant that guy would be charged with
double homicide naturally so I mean this
was always an issue that pro lifers
would bring up we'd say wait a second so
if a murderer goes and kills an unborn
baby that's murder but if a mother kills
an unborn baby that's a choice and
that's not murder at all that doesn't
make a lot of sense unfortunately we
were hoping that they would resolve that
contradiction in the favor of life
unfortunately Andrew Cuomo and the
Democrats or was
solving it in the favor of death they've
now removed a protection for an unborn
baby now up one minute before birth you
can kill that baby a murderer can kill
that baby won't be won't be charged with
killing it
obviously Andrew Cuomo is nominally a
Catholic sometimes he pretends to be a
Catholic and so this has raised some
questions should the Catholic Church
excommunicate Andrew Cuomo he is now
enabled babies to be killed one minute
before they're born this would seem
worthy of excommunication here are some
here's a bishop bishop of Albany
discussing it on Fox and Friends most
reverend Edwards Scharffen Berger joins
us now Reverend so firstly let's get
your reaction to this this new bill well
as you just said very well it was a
celebration of abortion which to me is a
celebration of death as a dehumanization
of a whole class of human beings in our
society the child in the womb who
clearly is a human subject that from the
moment of conception all the science
proves that so even though it has been
advertised as a bill that brings more
equality to women it excludes a certain
class of women the unborn half of all
abortions are females so I do not see
it's something that I would celebrate as
a matter of fact it extends actually it
takes away protections that previously
we had so Bishop Scharffen Berger being
very diplomatic here said well you know
it allows you to slaughter babies
wholesale so it's not something that I
would celebrate a very measured way to
put it but he's right he's right on that
point and he was asked if Andrew Cuomo
should be excommunicated and he says
well basically he says that he's
excommunicated himself that that Cuomo
probably is not in a place where he can
receive the Communion just for those of
you who don't know those who aren't
Catholic or frankly those who are
Catholic and don't know to be
excommunicated means that you are not in
communion with the church and very
practically means you can't receive the
communion you can't receive the
Eucharist the
host because you are not in communion so
he if you've got mortal sins on your
soul that you haven't confessed you are
not supposed to take the Eucharist you
are not in communion what the bishop is
saying is cuomo probably is in that
place right now unfortunately the
Cardinal in New York cardinal Dolan is
refusing to excommunicate Andrew Cuomo
there are other bishops here Bishop
Richard sticks teeka of Knoxville
Tennessee and Bishop Joseph Strickland
of Tyler Texas called for Andrew Cuomo
to be excommunicated but cardinal Dolan
a very powerful Cardinal and the
Cardinal of New York doesn't want to he
says it's not appropriate by canon law
he says that excommunication shouldn't
be used as a weapon out of anger and
frustration and that it would be used as
ammo by abortion activists that doesn't
really hold water to me I mean I defer
to greater experts on canon law but that
we're not using excommunication as a
weapon I mean in a sense it is a weapon
it is it is recourse by the church to
correct its flock who are erring gravely
and what is a more grave error than
allowing countless babies to be
slaughtered a minute before they're born
yeah if that's not a grave error what
what is if that's not worthy of the
weapon so-called of excommunication then
what is it's not out of anger and
frustration it's out of care for these
babies that are about to be slaughtered
and then to say it would be used as ammo
by pro-abortion activists who cares who
cares what they think
I don't answer to them who takes them
seriously it would be used as ammo
they've got plenty of ammo they use ammo
all the time they're constantly
attacking conservatives Catholics
Christians broadly there they don't who
cares why would you cater to them and
say well I don't want to give them an
excuse to not like the church they don't
like you they don't like you anyway you
can't make them like you you can't suck
up to them a little bit and then they'll
like you it's just not going to happen I
understand the real Prudential questions
of this the the Catholic Church has the
church has always had some relationship
to the state and
cardinal Dolan is the Cardinal in the
state that Governor Cuomo is the
governor of this would be a massive deal
if the Cardinal of New York were to
excommunicate the governor of New York
it would require an immense amount of
courage it might result in some serious
retribution against the church in New
York yeah that's all possible but if
you're not gonna muster up some courage
on this issue on the issue of the
wholesale slaughter of babies a minute
before they're born then what's the
point what's the point of having that
authority what are you doing if you're
not going to use it now then what why do
why do you have it in the first place
why do you have that authority was the
purpose of that authority and why if you
don't correct this action what will you
correct there is a good side of the
abortion debate though which is on the
political front the Democrats are going
insane they've been so triggered by the
culture but on the show shameless which
is a show with Bill Macy on Showtime I
think it's a really good show he's there
and he's it's a scene between him and
katey sagal who played Peg Bundy on
married with children and it's a scene
dealing with abortion and it actually
deals with abortion in a very honest way
genetics why would you try looks like
six of them have hunkered down in there
mom what babies embryos
I don't usually place all the fertilized
embryos in at once but at your advanced
age most woman's uterus aren't as
accommodating we're gonna have to
terminate a few of them five what it's a
safety issue carrying six embryos to
term poses a major health risk to the
mother what kind of health risk a months
of bed rest possible death you know what
let's just let's just keep one it's the
safest route I think the right dog what
I'd kill five of my babies now embryos
angee we want is many little Frankie's
and inky's running around this possible
that's obvious but do you really think
we can afford more than one
not a my income but you'll get a job
will keep five you can safely keep three
okay then for that's an amazing scene
that's a really powerful scene you've
got the doctor you've got the woman
who's clearly right here she's she's got
the babies inside of her she has a
motherly affection she says she's done
IVF she's got six babies in there she
says I'm not gonna kill my babies and
the doctor says one there no embryos
revised well what distinction is that
they're babies then you've got this
awful character of Bill Macy played by
Bill Macy
and he says let's kill five of them and
you run and it's really dark humour
because it's happening unfortunately but
it's dark humor that is making a really
true point and then she says well no you
got to kill three of them and and then
Katie said all it's haggling because she
wants to keep her babe it's normal to
want to keep your babies it's good to
want to keep your haggling over really
it this reminds me of a louis c.k bit
louis c.k did a bit in his act before he
was had his career destroyed where he he
did this line he said listen abortion
look it's just like going to the
bathroom okay right he's just you know
look it's going to the bathroom you go
you get to do it it's a physical act
that's all it is
or it's killing a baby right and it was
this amazing turn he got into some
trouble for it on the left because
that's what it is it's either you can
haggle over your babies and kill them
and pretend they're not babies just go
into the bathroom it's just a typical
procedure or it's a baby it's a human
life and I think we know which one it is
that's our show today come back tomorrow
we got a lot more to get to get your
mailbag questions and for Thursday
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick shyam hair and makeup is
by Jessa
of era the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19